there's my parents I want to say then
full names what happened to them Juke is
that you said these are my parents okay
pointing at yeah that was the jagat it
[Music]
these guys went to a school 10 minutes
from and then you know I got a creepy
Facebook message from Michael one day
and he's like you wouldn't be in the
band and I was I was waiting to being a
band I'd always wanted to be in a band
well you're in a cup of coffee 101 to
being a good band yeah my first real
success was a band called swallow the
goldfish
we had an amazing artwork it was a man
it looked like a corpse
no I antia had a goldfish I actually did
like that artwork cost me 220 bucks to
get that made us three had made an
unofficial dance but we didn't have a
name so we were just like in a band but
not really in a band jamming and then we
wanted to make it feel like we were
actually doing something and I wrote
like 20 30 names down we all took a look
at them and 5 seconds of summer stuck
out originally it was actually 5 second
summer which was actually much worse 5
second summer just didn't feel right and
also the acronym wasn't good yeah 5 5
SOS was 5 SOS always like I think when
we found that name it always felt really
special and there was something about it
that Juris towards it from the outside
you think Oh 5 seconds of summer like a
happy summer band blah blah but then if
you actually think about what it kind of
means you know it couldn't mean anything
[Music]
count going on his feet oh yeah you're
gonna have to take this one's important
because you got it when we left you in
Bali
yeah there was a story to that as well I
lost my passport in Bali so I stayed
back and me and my friend Roy who stayed
back with me because he's a true friend
weight shout-out to Roy
yeah wait we left him there and I got
Bali tour 1916 but with a little
extended you have another one
Oh your foot is so happy there you go
and he's got a seat on his foot he's
gonna see you in his arm you know what
but it was the first time that you guys
had ever hung out so we had a story of a
commitment that it's a true tale of
bromance bromance
yeah Nazi are forever really
ah I got none great so I'm the other one
of the band with no tattoos these are
red gel nails are going done in in
Sweden and they're again they're great
on stage this if I had it my way you
wouldn't be in this video
contractually okay I guess um one day
have another time at the moment those
like a brief period where everyone was
getting tattoos and I missed that boat
and now we have no time to get you guys
you guys I mean I haven't gone in like
three years
yeah so there's been no time for three
years what have you go my first one was
this one which says to the moon I was in
LA and I was 16 and I did not have my
Sorrento Vincent we were there with Liam
Payne one direction and then so we went
and I was super scared about it what
they did it and then Liam paid for it
and I never thanked him thanks Liam you
you started a tattoo adventure for me
which one did did Liam pay for your
tattoo as well names like Oprah yeah
yeah you get a tattoo
this one it's 2012 and Roman numerals
right it's when the band started first
tattoo ever got was when I was a 18 we
were on tour in a in England at the time
I had roughly 22 pounds to my name and I
spent 20 pounds getting this one and
that that was the first time I was ever
broke as well but it's my favorite
tattoo it's leaner
it's our bandits it means a lot and it
was you know it's funny because we also
kind of con dashed it into it we were
like ash we're all gonna get a
five-second summit a - we walk in me
account like I know weird kind of weird
and you had already started and we were
like looked at mine and they left the
store it was good ash looks good you
know I've actually seen a couple people
with this it's just a little anchor it
was basically just for me to tell myself
to stay grounded and I got that one done
it was as things started to get really
hectic first and I wanted to make sure I
told myself to you know remember what's
true and important to me such as Shamy
for God and then I forgot and the ex I
got done because Final Fantasy 10 is my
favorite game I started putting X's on
all of my guitars throughout the five
sauce campaign there were just so many
like little X's everywhere and then I
was like Final Fantasy 10 there are X's
everywhere I'm like X's obviously
something that is important in my life I
[Music]
got this heart it's made to look like a
birthmark I like little tattoos because
you know I'm committing but I'm not
committing to hard
I've been got really popular when we
were young and teenagers and I got this
hard tattoo cuz we saw a lot of the dark
and light in humans that I didn't quite
understand I didn't think I was ready to
understand a lot of it either it was
about me
remaining kind of softened and
attempting to love people when it's
right still and not becoming too
hardened in life
then I have so I have this it's a
California condor it's a slight fan
tattoo but it's also represents aa
starting a life for ourselves elsewhere
you know we have the classic pop punk
band story we've got to get out of our
town but we really did in a big way
which was cool you know we started a new
life for ourselves in California so I
kind of I've heard this about you about
like how it will look on stage like the
sticks are you hold them up like this
and from the back you want to be able to
see the tattoos on stage that's good
wow I didn't think of that this has a
live big p OD fan you know what's
interesting is that I actually wear a
key in this place called the giving key
that says alive on it mine said alive as
well I'm not gonna if you know but he
was actually telling story this is my
sister were you waiting for some snotty
remarks which ones are you getting the
same day I got this one and I got this
one which is supposed to be more like a
silver phone that's why my mom's from
but turned out like a feather so it kind
of sucks
I got a horseshoe here to bring me just
cause I ain't good luck has it worked
with friends like this yeah
it's raining good that bad still
together so yeah I got this on the same
day as Ashton got his sauce as you can
see a very talented tattoo artist says
skywards no one's ever liked being able
to read it before I've this one which is
a Scottish thistle it's my dad Scottish
and then this one my tattoo artist in
London sent me this and he goes what do
you think and I say I fell in love with
it and then he had heard it on me that
was purely just for art and then if you
take your top off and turn around he
actually has a beautiful portrait of me
these big bins they were a pain in the
ass I think this was the first legal
tattoo I got done
they went over this with like a 32-point
tattoo gun which is like imagine you can
draw one line or you can drill 32 of
them in about eight months they started
to fade really badly and really quickly
is that cause you're so pasty
I probably and so I had to go back in
and do another five hours of them
basically doing it again like and it
hurts the same as if you hadn't had it
done the first time my original plan for
it was I was gonna have things in
between these bands that represented
important milestones for me in my life
and you know obviously is meant to get I
was meant to get them done but I didn't
this one it's from one of my favorite
video games growing up Final Fantasy 10
and um the main character in the game he
wears this necklace with this charm on
it and it's for his hometown which is
zanuck and in the game and where you're
from and I'm I got it done basically
just to remind me of home etiquette I
think what I wanted to do is make this a
three-quarter sleeve so stop here and
how did this just another band normal I
reckon something to do with the album we
just made I was feeling it too yeah it's
young blood here's a promotion
I don't know probably I think you will
if you hang out with us any longer and
we go to like Vegas or something yeah
towns right with the third album I think
I'd probably do something around that
one thing that we try to do with our
expression and art is uh is constantly
break any expectation that anyone would
have had of us so we who are makeup we
were you know paint our nails we do all
these things it's a sense of accepting
yourself as a man and moving forward